Nicht mehr wegzudenken: die Freiheit,
die uns das Fahrrad bietet.
Einfach losradeln und die Gegend
genießen. Schnell von A nach B kommen.
All das haben wir Karl Freiherr
von Drais zu verdanken.
Er hat 1817 das Ur-Fahrrad erfunden.
Genau genommen war es
eine Laufmaschine.
Das Technoseum in Mannheim
zeigt die Geschichte des Fahrrads,
denn in Mannheim hat Karl von Drais
seine erste Fahrt unternommen.
Schon damals war vieles an dem
Gefährt so, wie wir es heute kennen
– nur die Pedalen fehlten.
Die Laufmaschine, das Ur-Fahrrad
des Freiherrn von Drais
hatte schon zwei gleich große
Räder, eine Lenkung.
Und auch eine Bremse
war schon vorgesehen.
Da ist vieles drin, was das neue Fahrrad,
das moderne Fahrrad ausmacht.
Trotz der genialen Idee ging das Produkt
noch nicht gleich durch die Decke.
Die Anschaffungskosten
von vierzig Gulden
überstiegen das Jahresgehalt
vieler Menschen.
Erst fünfzig Jahre später wurde
das Rad weiterentwickelt.
Beim „Tretkurbel-Velociped“
wurde das Vorderrad
nun mit zwei Pedalen angetrieben.
1867 wurde es auf der
Pariser Weltausstellung vorgestellt.
Es ging in Serie - hatte aber noch Tücken.
Das Velociped mit der
Tretkurbel im Vorderrad
war vor allen Dingen unglaublich schwer
mit einem schmiedeeisernen
Rahmen, aber,
und das war das Neue, man muss
die Füße vom Boden nehmen.
Das heißt, das Balancieren war
noch ein wesentlich komplizierterer Akt,
als es bei der Laufmaschine war.
Um noch schneller voranzukommen, wurde
das Vorderrad immer größer und höher
– bis zu anderthalb Metern.
Nun kam man zwar schnell vorwärts,
aber es kam auch zu gefährlichen Stürzen.
Daher steht das Modell hier
im Museum auf einem Ständer.
Ja, also, es is schon gut,
dass es jetzt hier aufm Ständer steht.
Also in der Natur würd‘ man
sich wahrscheinlich
nicht so weit nach oben trauen,
wenn man sich hier mal so umguckt.
Mehr Sicherheit gab es ab
den frühen 1880er-Jahren
mit dem Sicherheits-Niederrad
– mit zwei gleich großen Rädern.
Nun trieb eine Kette das Hinterrad an.
So ist es bis heute.
Um die Jahrhundertwende wurde
das Fahrrad zum Verkehrsmittel für alle.
War es anfangs noch Spielzeug des Adels,
machte es dann die Arbeiterschaft mobil.
Und auch Frauen stiegen aufs Rad:
Die ersten Frauen,
die Fahrrad gefahren sind
in den 1890ern, waren
extrem mutige Frauen.
Es bedeutete ja auch,
dass man seine Kleidung ändern musste.
Mit einem bodenlangen
Rock schwer möglich. Es verschaffte ihnen
die gleichen Freiheiten,
die es auch Männern verschafft hat.
Man war unabhängig, konnte größere
Strecken fahren, konnte Ausflüge machen
und entkam ein bisschen auch der
Kontrolle durch Familie, Ehemann,
wer immer da kontrollierte.
Für Licht am Fahrrad sorgte
zum Beispiel die Karbid-Lampe.
Karbid ist ein Gemisch aus
Calcium und Kohle.
Tropft Wasser drauf,
entsteht ein Gas, das brennt.
Wichtig war nur, dass
einem das Wasser nicht ausging.
Eine Möglichkeit wäre
gewesen, hineinzuspucken.
Was nicht sehr effektiv ist,
weil die Menge einfach zu gering ist.
Was die meisten Leute einfach
gemacht haben, die haben da reinuriniert.
Vor fast 100 Jahren hat man auch schon
Räder mit Hilfsmotoren ausprobiert –
die Vorläufer des Elektro-Bikes.
Doch trotz aller technischer Raffinesse
erlebte das Fahrrad ab den
1950ern eine erneute Durststrecke
durch den Boom von
Autos und Motorrädern.
Der Fahrradmarkt versuchte,
mit Klapprädern fürs Auto zu punkten.
Oder mit Bonanza-Rädern.
Und siehe da: Heute ist
das Fahrrad populärer denn je.
Wenn sie jemand[en] 1895
eingefroren hätten und die würden,
die würden den heute wieder auftauen,
dann würde er ganz viel nicht erkennen,
aber das Fahrrad wäre ihm geläufig.
Mountainbikes, City-Räder und E-Bikes
sind nicht mehr aus
unserem Alltag wegzudenken.
Und außerdem ist Fahrradfahren
gut für die Gesundheit – und die Umwelt.